certainly wants to move on as lucha
[ __ ] misses that but he's already two
different times
[Applause]
on the slam
beautiful setup
and this is voot score to the basket
right there slamming and jamming
so nice was short twice a rising mix
malfunctioning offense now
and they've got to tighten up their deep
crucial back to jones
the old-fashioned pick-and-roll that
time good job by caruso we were never
allowed to talk to the official my
coaches never wanted that so i was never
in the habit of doing it
ball three-pointer that's good
paul's just pummeling the knicks here in
the first he just tested positive roses
pass another deflection another turnover
though sumo throws it up for caruso
walker's been cheering him on the last
couple games like he's playing 40
minutes that it hasn't had an impact on
his spirit on the bench which shows you
again the character walker bad pass from
random before the nick's passing has
been brutal
his feed from caruso former leaker
watch out he has eyes in the side of his
head
to see jones right there with the
tomahawk stuff
he has been one of the most valuable
players in the league so far
boy derek rose had it lost it
got it back lost it again
the turnovers just killing the knicks
he has been one of the most valuable
players in the league so far boy derek
rose had it lost it
got it back lost it again
the turnover is just killing the knicks
derozan
man the
how freely the ball is moving
yeah
and that's snowball the layup
able to redeem himself this time
[Applause]
derozan feed inside caruso
and that's the continuity we mentioned
about
off the turnover obi topham lost the
handle goes back to get it stripped by
caruso he's the nba steals leader
per game of beautiful
everybody handling the ball like a hot
potato the knicks coughing up caruso did
watch the splendid pass
watch robinson with another rejection
the knicks go back down the court the
iq's gonna be open for a moment
and there's the foul right there derozan
picking up his third
he won't be after this
from saint agnes high school in
rockville center
caruso another steal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
has been amazing tonight look at the
good sleight of hand
finally